mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
le concert de l'orchestré national que
va diriger monsieur hagen brecht est
consacré ce soir à l'audition intégrale
de fidelio de beethoven qui vous sera
donné avec la distribution aux cobras et
si les honore geneviève moisan marceline
mode sabatier florestan à ribécourt dont
pixar michel roux rock qu henri médus
jacquinot joseph perron verlande andré
veyssière ténor solo michel hamel
baryton solo marcel vigneron coeur de la
radiodiffusion française chef des
choeurs marcel briclot la mise en ondes
musicales va être assurée par michel
philippot
quelques semaines avant sa mort alors
qu'il remettait à son ami schindler la
partition manuscrite de fidelio qu'il
gardait dissimulé dans sa chambre sous
des liasses de papier beterz prononça
ces mots de tous les enfants c'est elle
qui m'a coûté les pires douleurs de
l'enfantement c'est elle qui m'a causé
le plus de chagrin et c'est aussi pour
cela qu elle met la plus chère de
préférence à toutes les autres je la
tiens digne d'être gardée est utilisé
pour la science de l'art mais si le
sujet de fidelio au premier acte
l'action se passe en espagne dans une
prison d'état près de séville
dans la cour de la prison marceline la
fille du joli et roques co va co soins
du ménage tandis que jacquinot le
guichetier lui fait la cour marcelline
lui répondit ce traitement car elle
préfère le porte-clés fidelio et songe à
l'épouser elle ignore que sous
l'apparence de fidelio se dissimule une
femme la touchante léonore épouse de
flore et sans ajustement entre
emprisonné par le gouverneur pixar en
raison d'une haine personnelle depuis
deux ans la victime étant celui dans un
des plus profonds ou terrain et fidelio
n'a pas encore réussi à l'avoir par tous
les moyens cependant et le cherche à
obtenir la confiance du geôlier et à
l'accompagner lorsqu'il descend à seul
faire sa tournée dans les souterrains
mais voici qu'on annonçait un jour la
visite d'un ministre envoyée par l'état
car le bruit court que parmi les
prisonniers se trouvent des victimes
injustement condamné pizarro s'affale
ils font faire disparaître florestan il
ordonne aux jolies et de descendre
cachot et de décéder d'ouverture d'une
profonde si terme où l'on jettera la
dépouille de florestan après que pizarro
lui-même leurs actus et de sa main avant
d'entreprendre cette lugubre tâche rocco
accorde à fidelio de laisser les
prisonniers venir respirer pendant
quelques instants dans le jardin
mesdames messieurs voici sous la
direction de monsieur albrecht le
premier acte de fidelio
on
enfin
voilà
2 mon beau
oh
là
vous
enfin je suis seul avec vous on peut
donc aux maçons et
nous voyons bien qu andrew
les 120 air plus aimable sinon je perds
tous mes moyens
écoutez moi qu'incombe ont déplu et les
chocs récents propos
je
vous ai
je faisais une femme loisirs
ce moreau le sol corse attendent bon dit
bientôt nous sauvions emménagent
ensemble toujours cette porte mieux tous
se blesse avons fait et puis la chance
mais pas
méchant souvent là ce n'est pas
la forme
il
mais
courageux quand même en retard
voyons renonce à la faire il faut en
finir aujourd'hui sinon
revenir à mon meilleur niveau
faut-il preuve qui de toute espérance en
eau par
tous ces
jeunes auraient plutôt regarder en
silence
au diable toujours cette porte au diable
entretien
notre tour entretien maudite coveo
mobile corée
toutefois
jacqueline aux latinos nota tue pas mon
père s'appelle il peut attendre tu auras
beau faire je t'aimerai malgré toi mais
va dont mon père sans doute les saveurs
wi fi des livres de [ __ ] monsieur
fidelio est entré dans ce canton l'on ne
voit plus que lui en de recherche que
lui en dessous que plus que de lui kg
attends moi dans un instant je serai de
retour
pauvre garçon coup de mou et même de
plaider points mais depuis l'arrivée de
fidelio tout est changé je ne sais ce
qui se passe en moi
oh
m
et bien marceline monsieur fi des lions
n'est pas encore de retour non mon père
il aura sans doute été forcés d'attendre
longtemps chez le forgeron le voici sais
pas si mon pauvre fille d'elliot que au
moins assez chargé j'ai cru qu'on en
finirait jamais de rock roadie ces
maudites chaîne mais je ne crois pas que
les prisonniers parviennent maintenant à
les briser on n'a pas plus de zèle et
pas plus d'intelligence
aussi je sens que chaque jour je
m'attache à toi davantage et fars tu
seras récompensé de ses peines
crois tu que mes yeux ne lisent pas dans
ton coeur
oh
et mon homme
et
m
hello
oh
m
c
oh
la loi
hamon
à
son ami c'est rennes où sont à consulter
ils sont pour
avec bien sûr
le 13
et
écoute fidelio bien que tu ignores ta
naissance peux tu sois cent par an je
suis décidé à faire de toi mon gendre
dès que le gouverneur sera parti pour
ces villes que nous serons plus à notre
aise il doit partir sous peu de jours et
je vous marie le lendemain de son départ
vous pouvez y compter le lendemain de
son départ le lendemain de son départ ah
ça mes enfants vous vous aimez bien
n'est ce pas mais ça ne suffit pas pour
être heureuse en ménage il faut encore
maison
par son ennui c'est la misère
zéré la blonde là
a bordeaux
oui
oh
mais quand dans sa bouche selon laquelle
je sais qu offrait son chemin marc
lamour
sachet de ce vendée s'achever
nous recevons des sens
oui son argent pas de bonheur à qui des
motards
pas de bol
rien est rien unis et ensemble nous faut
qu'on regroupe
une amoureuse
aussi mes enfants ne forme bienveillant
remplissent bien votre escarcelle
et
pour paris et sa bien garni si l'on se
plaît tant
ac on se plaît elle a dit
oui sans argent pas bonne
2 ap m
oh
mon endroit
vous avez vous dira m reco l'union de
deux coeurs rien assorti et la source du
vrai bonheur et l'amour conjugal surtout
doit être le premier trésor qui existent
sur la terre il est un autre trésor
cependant qu'il ne me serais pas moins
précieux mais tous mes efforts je le
vois avec douleur ne pourront le faire
obtenir et quel est ce trésor votre
confiant ma confiance souvent je veux
voir revenir des souterrains de ce
château hors d'haleine et toutes
épuisées fois le maître ne me
permettrais lui pas de vous dire
compagnie il me serait si doux de vous
aider dans vos travaux j'ai les ordres
les plus précis de ne laisser pénétrer
qui que ce soit auprès des prisonniers
d'êta c'est bien dit mais il y en a tant
dans cette forteresse vous vous tuer
aussi mon père est la raison pour mettre
euros qu on c'est certain et il faudra
bien que le gouverneur malgré toute sa
sévérité me permettent de produire avec
moi dans les cachots du secret il en est
ainsi pendant où malgré que je sois bien
sûr de toi dont pizzaro ne souffrira
jamais que je te conduise n'est ce pas
celui de ce prisonnier dont vous nous
parlez quelquefois justement il y a
longtemps je crois qu'il est dans ces
prisons deux en deux ans dites vous il
faut que ce soit un grand criminel ou
qu'il est grand ennemi cela revient à
peu près au même nous n'avons jamais pu
savoir d'où ils étaient ni comment elles
se nomment il a souvent voulu jaser de
tout cela avec moi bien mais comme dans
mon état il faut se donner le moins
qu'on peu de secrets à garder je n'ai
pas voulu l'entendre
oh
il ne tournera pas longtemps celui là
commandes ont des ordres sont donnés de
le laisser périr de fins il
depuis un mois dont pizzaro me fait
réduire chaque jour sa portion il n'a
plus que 2 11 de pain noir par 24 heures
et une demi-mesure d'eau jamais de
lumière que celle de ma lanterne
plus de paille rien
rien
regardez regardez vous bien les conduire
- fidelio pourquoi donc aux jets de la
force et du courage
il faut vouloir des faubourgs
montré du courage le radier
à voir de près
les plus heureux o
o
bon
oh
j'ai
confiance
non
m
on
le coup la chose est claire
mon
m
bon
tout ira bien j'en suis certain
m
à
et
allons il est temps d'aller remettre les
dépêches au gouverneur justement le
voici comme les mois et éloignées
on
y at il quelque chose de nouveau nom
seigneur où sont les dépêches les voici
tiens que vois-je je crois reconnaître
cette écriture
je vous donne avis que le ministre ayant
appris que les prisons d'état renferme
plusieurs victimes du pouvoir arbitraire
marc demain pour aller les visites
examiné lui même votre conduite prenez
vos précautions et tâcher s'il en étant
encore des shapiro ses recherches
s'il découvrait que je tiens ici dans
les fers ce flou restantes il croit
morts et dont j'ai ton sujet d'un
étranger ce florestan qui voulu me
dévoiler aux yeux de l'état emma haché
ses faveurs
il n'est pas parti à prendre oui c'est
le seul tout le reste
o o
et de servir ma mère au web
on habille
non à
hambourg brême
à des séances en paix
techart dijon 6 foyers tous fiers lilou
et
moi si mal
pour nous
sinon
s'alourdir et d'assouvir ma mère
je suis dans son histoire
victoire
m
comme on peut
consière des frappes des femmes
tu bosses moelleux
tutoyer
je sais pas
rage besson a fait rage
oui mais non
en france
il est
capitaine
montaison donjon avec un trompette dont
vous serez bien sûr vous regardera
attentivement sur la route de ces villes
aussitôt que vous apercevrez de loin car
ans accompagnée de plusieurs gardes vous
me ferez donné le signal par le
trompette à l'instant même entendez vous
le signalent à l'instant même rocco
affero presse ilna fortune
si tu serres mais vrai
ce tour
strato à plus tard
j'écoute à vos ordres quatre rendez-vous
de
fin d'année ou deux mois
gina
maréchaussée
et
dites
aux
écoutes mois de juin tu trembles un
vieux soldat manqué de peu
il pour hâter la chose pour des raisons
d'être à il faut que dès ce soir nous
supprimions cette reine
son écran
est avec six jeux à cet horaire être
métisse pape n y aurait pas
sans crainte à mort
mieux
nous
troisièmement descendre à mort
tu serais tu sais
non
mais
on sent qu'à chaud je voudrais te
rejoindre que la citerne
soit sont tombés
à l'eau
alors
juré mois
seulement
200 projets démarrés
et diligence c'est compris je pense
at on ainsi
à ses fins
le glissant dans l'ombre
c'est fait
c'est ça
le feu ça
m
coût
on va
il
pichot
au fond
lobo
enfants
non
romo
puis ville
payant
où
non
oh
m
m recours permettez-moi de vous rappeler
la promesse que vous m'avez fait de
laisser un jour les pauvres prisonniers
prendre l'air dans le par le ciel est si
pur aujourd'hui nous sans l'autorisation
du gouverneur et bien soit voici les
clefs fidelio et jacquinot ouvriront les
grilles j'irai retrouver le gouverneur
et je leur tiendrai le plus longtemps
que je pourrai
et
oh
à
et
nous
ouais
m
voir
mon
un peu long
je prends
et
raté
à
et
oh
on parlait plus non
quand
dans
on souhaite avancer
à
alors
oh
bah
non
est ce
on
prudence prudence
nuances
plus prudents
et
à
allons plus rares
pour marie va mon plus grand
le
oh
me réjouis toi bien que mal j'expliquais
tout gévezé notre angers et sa réponse
à la devinette uma
la place et puis mon mariage
frères
ne viendra faire aujourd'hui
il
est peut-être encore nous descendrons
strongle wind et sandro ensemble
de ce malheureux qui subit le martyre de
londres
magnifique
aux femmes et aux noms qui font peu plus
montrant
qu'il faut il faut avant 1h dans le
finistère nous l'ayons son terme il
faut mettre à mal
vos propos
tellement grand
bonjour
mais
allons nous faut presser ouvrage je fus
mammeri sur le toit jantes
une
durée souvent notre métier
nous avons d'autres choses à
décompresser
la
contenir ap
nous y sommes
si je ferai j'irais bien seul
mais le ballon d or
et puis il faut faire
blessé
formelle
reste ici tu va m'attendre tu va
m'apprendre j'y resterai puis bah
maintenant
m
oh
tu as des boutons ne tardez pas
expliquez vous voit sort et il a tout
appris
dgo
non
mais bon
la liberté lamballe de nez à nez série
sonny des baigneurs on est vraiment
le site
les quais de souffle du bâton puis
laissez moi pour demain dépose un
bouquet manuels anciens
nous célébrons ainsi ce jour plus âgées
profil autres
les saisons passent aussi respirer
pendant une heure pour l'autre quart des
bourriques ce serait bien fera donc
resserré sa tombe je ne veux pas aussi
de troubles à l'instant clairement ferme
common tarder at what we au garde à toi
on est
quel moment
non
c'est de montceau
à
et
ces droits sorte car si je pouvais
saisir à nous
2 - peut-être
à
non
m
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs nous
allons interrompre ici après les
premiers actes l'audition de fidelio
l'opéra de better auquel est consacré ce
soir le concert de l'orchestré nationale
que dirige monsieur albrecht dans dix
minutes le second acte de fidelio
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs voici
maintenant le deuxième acte de fidelio
de beethoven
coeur de filet lloba très fort car le
geôlier l'emmène avec lui pour l'aider
dans cette tragique bosal elle va donc
revoir son mari au fond de leurs rible
souterrain une loque humaine seclin
attaché à une chaîne scellé dans le mur
roques co et fidelio s'approche
tremblante
léonore reconnaît son mari une fois
encore florissants plaide son innocence
tandis que sa femme dégage tant bien que
mal la sinistre citerne
pizzaro survient le poignard à la main
mais au moment où il s'approche de
florestan
léonore s'interpose se fait reconnaître
de son mari et menaces pizza d'un
pistolet tiré de son sein
ce délai permettra au ministre d'état
d'arriver à temps pour les sauver du
front de la geôle sombre on entend
éclaté le son de la trompette ma
constance a vaincu mon amour triomphe
s'exclame fidelio pleurant de joie dans
les bras de son mari le ministre ami
personnel de florestan fait arrêter
pizza on enchaînera à la place de
florestan
obscurité
m
si l'ombre
c'est pas lui
whissell
dans l'univers
sourire
c'est 3 le maire
mais joue
mais
e
moi
eh
oui
l'enfant
oh
où
non non non
non
suite
oh
dans
et
moi je m'accorde cycle m
adorable mamie tu
sens qu'il
me touche de la le
filon
oh
un
produit de cette source
non
la gauche de l'air
ces trois niveaux
en revanche ressenti
moi
bastien
outre à l'abîmé
outre m
il faut voir dans ces souterrains ce
n'est pas étonnant il est si profond
j'ai cru que nous ne trouverions jamais
l'entrée
voici le prisonnier ils paraissent en
mouvement
il est peut être mort
non il sommeille
il faut en profiter pour nous mettre à
l'oeuvre à nous n'avons pas de temps à
perdre
possible de distinguer aucun d'eux se
traîne
au milieu cissé lui protège moi
c'est là que se trouve la citerne
il ne s'agit que de creuser un peu afin
de dégager l'entrée danois 7 pioche et
mets toi là
je tremble
as tu perds
non j'ai froid tu vas te réchauffer en
travaillant
mais m
on doit venir
je pense que
oh
rome 2
alors
c'est bien
et
m
heureux
oh
allons
m
à
on va
rodet
on
il se réveille il serait l'aï dit du oui
oui il vient de relever la tête il va
faire sans doute encore mille questions
il faut que je lui par le seul qui
d'elio des sens à ma place et achève
d'enlever le reste de ses décombres
eh bien vous venez de prendre quelques
moments de repos c'est toujours ça du
repos où trouver le repos cette fois
sauvé vous toujours insensible aux cris
l'innocent grand dieu c'est lui et que
voulez vous que je fasse j'exécute les
ordres qu'on me donne c'est mon métier
ne pourriez-vous son enquête votre
devoir apprendre enfin quel est le
gouverneur de ses prisons je ne risque
rien maintenant le satisferait le
gouverneur de ces prisons ces dons pizza
pizza
c'est lui dont josé divulguer les crimes
fais-toi l'amitié d'envoyer au plus tôt
à seville et vous y ferez demandé sur la
place d'armes la demeure de léonard
florist en dieu il est loin de penser
qu'en ce moment elle creuse sa tombe
dites-lui que j'existe encore ekissi
j'agonise dans les fers possible vous
dis-je je me perdrais sans vous être
utile et bien alors s'il faut que je
termine ici mon sort soyez humains et ne
me laissait pas expiré lentement de
misère et de besoin
par pitié une goutte d'eau c'est bien
peu de choses je suis ému malgré moi ils
paraissent attendrir vous nous répondez
rien tout ce que je puis vous offrir
c'est un peu de vin que j'ai la fidelio
voilà voilà quel est ce jeune homme mon
porte clés et mon gendre sont peu de
jours comme thue et mue fidelio qui ne
serait pas vous-même m recours c'est
vrai cet homme a une voix oui qui
pénètre jusqu'au fond du coeur
non
rené terme
oh
les prendre
monde
non
il
faut
pouvoir
oh
et
une fête
on
voit combien ce qu'on en compte
non
c'est peu le plan
rigole
vraiment
d'autres qu'eux
les corps de poids tout nous porte et
ne commet pas
merci
laisse coi en
forme
de trapèze
ouais
c
tout est prête je vais donner le signal
c'est ici qu'il faut de la force et de
courage
kelly signale effrayant est ce ma mort
qu'on prépare non rassurez-vous ou mal
et au nord je ne te verrai non plus tout
leur silence vers lui rassurez-vous moi
que vous puissiez voir ou entendre
souvenez-vous que partout il est une
providence
il vient une providence
record tout est-il prêt oui il ne s'agit
que nourrir la citerne c'est bon faire
retirer ce jeune homme alors éloigne toi
qui moi et vous ne faut-il pas que je
détache les terres du prisonnier pour
que tout soit à jamais en se veut ni
dans le silence je me des frais 2 avant
la fin du jour faut-il le déchaîné nom
des tâches la pierre le temps presse
d'abord ils sont chauds
on veut
ce jeu
quand
nous reconnaissons
travaux
et c'en
est une autre
oh
au monde
mieux
le protoss
oui je suis libre
non
je suis heureux
après
c'est beau
bref
m
rko le ministre arrive dieu soit loué
nous augmentons tout de suite et
défendre des flambeaux pour éclairer
monsieur le gouverneur
jeudi également
m
enfin ça
monde unix temps de
chez moi
oh
et
histoire
plus
avant
m
vous
e
et
à
temps
copé
à
là
soit
aujourd'hui
rjc soleil
et
à
moi je l voulez vous mettre en
découdre en grâce
monseigneur
dernier ces deux époux pas non plus
j'amorce les comédiens sont membres
travaillent bien de mon
e
rennes
bonjour
comment
résister
elle se mit à mon service dans des
cimetières
g
au
monde
je voulais pas
maurice au total n'est pas seul
monsieur
prévost
les hommes sortent des stands
ouais
voir
lui
e
oh
m
je suis je
et
oh
à
on va
je
à
mais
oh
m
d'accord
les enfants
l'arrêt
m
à
papa
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs du
fidelio berhad bétonne nous a été
présentée aujourd'hui avec le concours
de geneviève moisan dans léonard mode
sabatier marceline en ribécourt
florestan michel roux dont pizza henry
met du rock coco joseph perron jacquinot
andré veyssière dont vernant ténor solo
michel hamel baryton solo marcel
vigneron solistes choeur de la
radiodiffusion française chef des
choeurs marcel briclot et orchestre
national était sous la direction de
monsieur à égal brecht milon musicale
michel philippot